[Music]
anyone in this room not know what
mindfulness is yeah yes I don't know
okay I do buy them is mindfulness where
you try to be like extremely present and
self-aware so you're you you can feel
you can you know what emotions are
feeling instead of just being engulfed
in it and just happening yeah I would
have thought I grew up booty so that's
basically all of Buddhism yeah
everything you know what it is it's what
all Asian auntie's think they have but
they don't explain they're not mindful
because they just live life the way they
want to they go trust me I know what I'm
angry I'm angry you have to be mindful
of your surrounding Family Guy and your
energy and your mind
that's Buddhism it's do you see yourself
see more mm-hmm
constantly yeah never perfect are you
allowed to beat your kids being a
Buddhist yes Confucius say [ __ ] yeah
indirectly yeah that two different
things like Buddhism in kung-fu
yeah but I think in Asian culture they
kind of go inner lon yeah I think Taoism
is more of like is that just a cute way
of saying terrorism yeah you've been
listening to its operative on tape so I
think Confucianism is more of like a way
of culture and being and it's not so
much a religion it's just the principles
that he put forth so it'd be like
Socrates teachings or like play those
teachings is more like I created a
structure of how society can be the best
yeah
and the Taoism that's actually a
religion
Confucianism Confucianism is by
Confucius he is the founder and he
created a structure to make society
orderly and make it like run smooth and
whatever yeah how you talk to your
elders how you talk to your parents the
dynamic at work all about the rules yeah
and then the t-word towel how is that
that's more of like their Chinese like
indigenous religious type of religion
and then they made Confucius a deity in
it so they've made him like okay like
we're gonna worship this guy we also
worship a bunch of other gods but we
worship this guy too
it's called the way so so like the way
that a lot of like Chinese people
practice Buddhism maybe even Vietnamese
it's like a cross between Buddhism and
Confucianism so just like how the
Catholics in Italy may practice it way
different than America Mexican American
person practice Catholicism here because
you're just culture just seeps in and
you interpret the the manuscripts
differently so it's just it's like way
different than how Indians are practice
Buddhism yeah and each of those
religions have so many different sects
too so I'm pretty sure like the real way
of Buddhism you're not supposed to be
beating the [ __ ] out of it you go
designo beat the [ __ ] out well yeah this
turned into religion but right here
we're focusing on specifically
mindfulness cuz you know that's like the
new trend right now a lot of people are
really like focusing on being more
present and meditating and especially
since a lot of people have heard that
you get a lot of benefits from it oh
yeah for example Steve Jobs brain was
like 27 or something when he died
because he always would meditate and he
was always he was Buddhist yes but it
helped him with his cancer though right
nice and healthy and young he chose not
to pick tree you know got in you know
what he was taking supplements yeah he
was he was taking like 50 different
supplements every day or whether it's
job' holistic he was mindful but then I
know he was
you have you did a thing it was like
sleeping with the iPhone one gave them
cancer or something
yeah there's radiation on these things
anyways so I have this article from
Psychology Today where they're talking
about how mindfulness can actually be
bad for you Wow yeah so too mindful yeah
what's going on here the Shaolin monks
are gonna come and kick their ass yeah
you're flying through the windows
alright so you should ISM yeah okay yeah
okay so to shorten this whole article
here they're saying that mindfulness can
be often considered to have two main
components which is awareness and that's
the one that we all have been talking
about and then the other one which is
the most important one too is acceptance
so you're supposed to be aware and fully
present of every single passing moment
and as your present let's say I'm being
mindful and I'm angry and then like I
feel this I'm being mindful of how this
emotion is affecting me but then I
accept that I'm angry I accept that
emotion and by like through that
acceptance is is where the growth comes
in so you feel the burn and you're
supposed to go it's okay to be angry and
you grab a chair and slam it no it's
more like like it's okay to be angry I'm
not gonna like it's it's gonna pass
through me it's not sue me which is like
don't bury it down deep that's what I do
I think I feel that passing through me
and then I laugh or the most people do
that and that's actually what's
happening here where where mindfulness
can be bad for you because people aren't
doing that second part which is the
acceptance part so by that by everyone
constantly being aware of everything
they're actually getting more anxiety
more depression more everything that's
yeah it's cuz ignorance is bliss I play
with my emotions like dodgeball I see it
coming I'm like ooh
Galloway why I don't think I'm better
because I do that I grab it [ __ ] yeah
where it's like say I just wake up for
some reason sad right or just like it's
not my day I tricked myself into it
being a good day than I have a good day
bye Howie jackoff
I mean good I was really frustrated the
other day cuz I was trying not to jack
off and I did took a three hour nap I
feel great what were you trying not to
jack up yeah my day class or looks like
that hour before yeah our breaks
probably I don't know man I think I
gotta give it a rest you know yeah did
we never talk about this yeah did you
guys have [ __ ] bonded on the bottles
that you both have the oil and through
text the man oil it did make my dick
skin more sensitive by the way you were
right I did it every day it's who you've
been sexting I have a jacked off in two
weeks now to it and I broke it yesterday
Wow why did you why did you break it I
was just a board or a working for now
are the see right yeah we wanted to see
if it helped to see your come again
blinded oh but it took I swear you got
less than 30 seconds Wow is that bad
well it's good I made it more sensitive
cuz of the oil I mean I think it's also
not jacking off oh I can't do that
anymore well you need to take a break
probably probably the thing is like once
you stop this is a whole part of the
mindfulness yes I believe you I believe
you um I was gonna get to that but go
ahead yeah yeah so then uh when she
stopped jacking off you you slowly cut
it's like getting off of like saying
smoking or something I would have known
you has a theme song for that what
sing it is going original you go and
then you stop like you stop getting
interested and now it's like the second
like if you can see Jack it off you
think of it you're gonna have to do Yeah
right
once you stop then it makes it so much
better not to than you're like I don't
need to but there's a negative effect to
that because everyone's talking about
this whole nofap thing right so nofap is
like then we want it where you talking
about that you use it or lose it a lot
of yeah a lot of the men on the on the
on the internet oh yeah I've been I went
through months without playing with my
wit with wiggly wieners mushiya dogs
right yeah got two of them yeah my
English Long's I'm not I'm not trying to
get
you know this channel canceled and [ __ ]
so I didn't want to say David yeah so I
don't want to say word yeah no but what
what there's a the negative affective is
if you don't think about sex if you
don't touch yourself or like work any
it's like it's like a muscle its organ
but if you don't use it you do lose it
your school so still think about it like
this maybe I don't I did it though for a
long time and I was like what is this a
penis don't feel nothing that should do
cos like drinking like dry spells and
then after our dry spell I feel like I'm
losing my virginity again yeah this [ __ ]
is tight it's like what been too tight
you're like a monk it is no no it's not
good or bad actually tight why there's a
balance there's a good balance yeah
anyway back to these things so they're
saying here that it's by not practicing
the acceptance part of things it's
almost like as if when you think about
your physical body and when you have a
sprained ankle and then you go run on
that sprained ankle you're not helping
that ankle you're actually making it
worse because you need it to recover
before you go out and work on that ankle
so just like what you're doing here or
like what a lot of people are doing here
we're with mindfulness they're they're
being hyper aware they're very very
aware below so they see all the problems
not having that acceptance part they're
actually hurting themselves they're
harming their their their brain their
emotions like their mental health is
actually getting worse I come to my
Buddhist class right now so I feel like
I'm gonna lie Buddhist class right now
that's basically what the monk talks
about for like an hour really so
technically the mindfulness does work is
just people aren't going through it yeah
so then the psychologists are [ __ ] it
up by saying that it doesn't work
because if people went through it the
right way then it does work that's like
saying hey man therapy doesn't work well
what you were supposed to do in therapy
they're not saying it doesn't work
they're just saying it can be bad for
you it can't be harmful if you don't do
it all exactly cuz it's something that
not a lot of people will have even
realized like me myself reading this I
was like oh [ __ ] that's true like if
you're not
it just makes perfect sense if you're
you're only being hyper aware you're not
doing anything about that like you're
just gonna be hurting yourself and
getting more depressed more anxiety it's
kind of like how when people start
dating woke and you see all the problems
in the world and then they get even more
stress now it's like what are you gonna
do exactly what's happening and exactly
but I like to empower myself by saying
you know what let me look the other way
and go jack off to porn empowerment and
then I clear my mind and then I figure
out a solution because that song plays
and I become positive and I go now it's
time to save the world and I think being
involved in something and making a
difference that's the action part in
your own self and in other people yeah
hell yeah
yeah that's definitely the hardest part
where people like they just stop because
either they don't know how they're not
or they just don't accept it and they're
just like no I don't even think it's
that and it just they just feel it and
then it just stops and then it's like
well now what do I do
I feel like [ __ ] yeah yeah it becomes
overwhelming I think that's what it is
cuz you the the I think it's the stages
of waking up right so like the first
stage is the self-awareness part where
you can all wait I don't have to react
this way to the feeling I have cut the
second arrow yeah about that second
arrow thing I'm like within yourself so
you feel it right what is that yeah
explain told you guys so um the second
arrow thing is like you know everyone
gets hit with that first arrow and this
first arrow is like you had no control
over it like like you go in a car
accident okay yeah yeah that's the first
arrow you are responsible for that
second arrow that you get hit with
because you're the one that's consuming
yourself with like [ __ ] I'm so stupid I
got into that car crash I could have
avoided whatever like ah
that's the second arrow is you harming
yourself and the point of I think in
mindfulness are just in Buddhism is that
we [ __ ] ourselves over when we create
judgment on that what happened the first
time yeah like we get into a car
accident or whatever right if you tell
yourself like I deserve it cuz of karma
that's the that's on you for creating
that or someone else can blame that
[ __ ] that crashed into me they were
they were on their phone [ __ ] them
that's another issue that you're
creating if you just didn't have to
reason and
you were okay and just like okay just an
accident there okay yeah that's that's
just you just [ __ ] move on yeah true
of mine yeah well in that something that
you can't even control I mean going with
that specific example there's a lot of
[ __ ] that we can't control that we're
always trying to [ __ ] control and
because we can't control it then we get
[ __ ] down on ourselves and it's like
bro you can't controllers well couldn't
let it go that's true
people get mad at me for not having the
second arrow you don't have one
for reals like what like you play dodge
ball out there blind by this Nelson no
like again to like show a motorcycle ass
and I'm like oh that happened and people
come pick me up and they're like why
don't you like freaking out my picture
like the matrix with me oh he's getting
hit and [ __ ] and then like he comes up
and all this bullets come out I get
tired of the feeling I want to be angry
for entertainment but not in real life
hell yeah I feel like I'm too chill I
gotta drop my phone and it'll crack and
I'll just would put it down won't even
think about it that's awesome yeah I
mean it's a [ __ ] phone that's know
yeah one more thing you'll be like come
on wallet Kennedy saving his energy for
jacking off
[Music]
[Music]